mac and cheese
fine wine
and ice cream
there's something surprising they have
in common and that's thomas jefferson
thomas jefferson
founding father
third president and author of the
declaration of independence
pretty impressive resume
but what we should really recognize
jefferson for is being a massive foodie
while serving as the ambassador to
france in the late 1700s he developed a
specific appreciation for all things
european
while touring europe he took detailed
notes about modern farming and
agricultural techniques
upon returning to the us he began
cultivating his own organic vegetable
garden berry patch and vineyard
he even had a macaroni pasta machine
shipped over and introduced ice cream to
his kitchen
after he was elected as president he
brought his passion for food to the
white house he even served one of his
favorites macaroni and cheese at a state
dinner in 1802
even though he didn't come up with the
dinner recipes himself jefferson helped
popularize them by serving them at
decadent dinner parties
[Music]
so next time you reach for your favorite
guilty pleasure say a small thanks to
thomas jefferson
mr president our taste buds salute you
cakes cookies and brownies no we're not
going to show you how to make them
because they can be made with ease
thanks to betty crocker who was born in
1921 in minnesota
well kind of
[Music]
in 1921 the washburn crosby company now
known as general mills ran a contest for
people to complete a puzzle for the most
coveted prize a pincushion yes one of
your very own
surprisingly a lot of people wrote in to
claim their prize but with a little ps
how do i make my sponges
they wanted baking advice
so the customer service department began
to reply and to make their tips seem
more genuine they signed their letters
betty crocker
betty because it was a cheery all-around
american sounding name and cracker after
a board member
not being a real person didn't stop
betty crocker from having a very
successful radio show the betty crocker
cooking school of the air
with a different accent in every state
[Music]
betty crocker cooking
[Music]
but the lies don't stop there let's talk
about that added ingredient the egg
you don't need to add a fresh egg to
powdered cake mix but science says it
makes us feel like we aren't cheating
and we're better providers
so thanks betty crocker for making us
all feel like we know how to bake
[Music]
salmon sushi isn't japanese
it's norwegian
[Music]
huh sushi okay here's the story until
about 1995 raw salmon was not consumed
in japan and this was for one big reason
pacific salmon has parasites
so no salmon sushi sashimi no spicy
salmon nothing what no way but obviously
that all changed thanks in part to this
guy
yes my my name is bjorn eric olsen
norway had a problem they had a lot of
salmon and too small a market looking
east they set their sights on japan a
country that loves raw fish so much it's
willing to pay five times the price for
sushi grade
so norway formed a committee and hired
bjorn
from 1986
to 1991 i worked for project japan
their job was to convince japanese
consumers that atlantic salmon was safe
to consume raw and this was hard
just take for example pork if some guy
from norway came here and said here eat
our pork meat raw it's safe it's really
yummy we'd be like man you're crazy
it was basically a matter of perception
so we had to change
the whole country in a way
bjorn and his team got to work they made
the first ever salmon rolls and served
them to businessmen in japan which they
didn't like
for a long time
it took actually 10 years to get a
proper breakthrough in the market
so there it is sam and sushi didn't
exist before 1995. bjorn on behalf of
the world
we thank you
whether you're in it for the bottomless
mimosas the decadent pancakes or the
avocado toast brunch is hands down the
best part of the weekend
while enjoying the finer things in life
did you ever stop to think about how
this glorious eating tradition began
well it all started with a man a man
with a hangover
[Music]
back in 1895 there was this guy named
well guy and he was a writer living in
england at that time sundays were a big
deal and early post church meat heavy
meals were all the rage but for those
nursing a hangover and recovering from
the previous night's debauchery those
meals weren't always appetizing so guy
proposed a compromise and penned a
prolific essay appropriately named
brunch a plea
he envisioned a hybrid meal of sorts
that was lighter than the typical meat
spread and included a variety of
pastries friends could gossip about the
previous night's indiscretions while
chasing their hangovers with some hair
of the dog but the delicious british
invention took what seems like forever
30 years to catch on in the states when
it did sunday morning never looked the
same again so the next time you're
enjoying a french toast chased by a
bloody mary take a second to thank the
hard-drinking englishman by the name of
guy
[Music]
you